manit eggs benedict want a cracker cuz
that's what parts like right this isn't
like Pitt I mean he's like well he's me
and he flies around and stuff it's not
like him to get pinned by Burrell see
he's a slippery as a grease brawl maybe
no I can't believe I'm gonna say this
maybe he was winging it and things went
south hahaha points out that's funny oh
well Oh anyway if the you view our
quartermaster did the job they're
supposed to be doing they would have
approved our supply requisitions before
we ran low on artillery got overrun you
gotta think about where those supplies
would come from bud anyone we take him
from out here is fighting too yeah like
who like the Eldred yeah they're just
collateral damage collateral damage look
could you say something like that stop
sucking up to the brass Monty you're so
focused on keeping everyone safe you
just end up making decisions that put
people more in harm's way
well I bad for not just indiscriminately
blowing everything up I didn't say
anything about blindly destroying things
but at what point are we going to go all
in and stopping this war Oh in shouldn't
mean sacrificing the people we're trying
to save if we do that what are we really
accomplished more than wasting our time
trying to get a semi flightless bird the
trigger is nesting instinct right
benedict man I hate that avian look but
all I'm trying to say is the longer we
drag this out the more the difficult
choices become the only choices and I
for one can think of a million better
ways I could be spending my afternoon
yeah like clearing out spider colonies
on orb on seven hey it's man mountain
and comfy boy i got something stuck in
this hair trawl man i really hate this
guy I could really use some help you
know who wants to be my wingman ahahaha
give that back you can t'kul freak yep
save them all even this guy
you